(cliquetis d'appareil photo)
- C'est un des premiers crimes
sa guerre contre l'Ukraine,
commençée, en fait, il y a hui
ans. Le vol MH17 de la Malaysian
Airlines, reliant Amsterdam
et Kuala Lumpur est abattu
par un missile Bouk russe.
Crime de erererre majeur
puisque 298 passagers
de plusieurs pays sont morts.
Dontaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaia.
C'est pour ça que
le procès, ouvert en 2020,
s'est te
Coupable de l'écrasement
intentionnel illégal de l'avion,
et meurtres, Igor Girkin,
colonel du FSB, les services
secrets russes, soi-disant
la République populaire
séparatiste de Doniesk,
du FSB Serguei Dubinskiy et
l'ukrainien Leonid Karchenko,
ils sont accusés d'avoir importé
de Russie le lance-missile Bouk
et donné l'ordre d'abattre
ce qu'ils croyaient être
un avion de guerre ukrainien.
Le quatrième accusé est
acquitté. Moscou a nié
toute responsabilité et nie
encore après avoir exposé,
à grands frais, qua
XAVIER TYTELMAN, consultant
aéronautique, etetet Cosmos
- Et je me souvinananananananant
déjà dans les plateaux et
j'avais beau d d de difficultés
à expliquer une minute pourquoi
tel et tel argument était faux.
C'est fffffffffffffffffffffffff.
Il y a un radar d'un côté
il y a un missile de l'autre,
c'est 6, 8, 10 personnes
qui vont travailler ense
Xavier Tytelman suit l'affaire
depuis le premier  e e et
il parle d'une enquête
impeccable en dépit
des obstruct
- Et, ururur et à mesure que
la Russie s'enfonçait dans
ses mensonges, on avait déjà,
dètitititititititititititititite
de missiles avait été tiré,
rcrcrce qu'on avait des morceau.
Des dizaines de journalistes
et de soldats et de... également
des citoyens ukrainiens ont vu
passer le porteur du missile,
le missile sur le toit.
- L'enquête, extrêmement
minutieuse, a impliqué
les familles des victimes
à toutes les étapes, et a
produit un rapport qui est
Bouk a pu faire ce genre
de dégâts près du cockpit.
Et les débris ont même permis
d'identifier de quel missile
exactement il s'agissait,
- s s s s s s s s s s s s s s sx
faites que j'ai pu observer.
cococontre, le fait que
ces coupables ne se retrouvent
jamais derrière les barreaux
que personne ne peut
s'en satisfaire.
- Pour les familles
directs sont condamnés, mais
les vrais responsables sont
ceux qui ont déclaré la guerre.
"C'est la guerre qui a pris
la vie des 298 passa d d du vol
MH17, c'est l'agression russe
en Ukraine. On veut la fin
de cette guerr
L'enquête et le procès du vol
171717 resteront comme un modèle
pour les crimes de guerre,
qui ne manqueront pas d'être
ukrainien, quelle que soit
son issue.
Ici Jean-Michel Lepri
Radio-Canada, Montréa